[Music]
Wall Street Journal reporter Evan
gushkeritz remains a Russian prisoner
after losing his appeal against the
extension of his detention earlier this
week he will remain in prison ahead of
his trial for Espionage the White House
has repeatedly condemned the Kremlin for
this calling it repression of the
freedom of the press State Department
spokesman vedant Patel echoed those
sentiments in Wednesday's press
conference saying we we continue to feel
that the this whole legal process as it
relates to Evan is a sham we've been
very clear that Evan is wrongfully
detained gershkovitz is being held at
the notorious lefortova prison in Moscow
where he now faces up to 20 years in
jail in his court appearance for the
decision Evan stood in a glass cage
wearing a dark T-shirt and jeans smiling
briefly to the media before they were
ordered out of the Court Evan's parents
also attended the hearing as did the U.S
ambassador to Russia Lynn Tracy who
spoke about Evan's strength Evan
continued to show remarkable strength
and resiliency in these very difficult
circumstances but Evan is not the only
American who remains a Russian prisoner
former Marine Paul Whalen is still being
held in Russia under Espionage charges
and has been in a prison camp for the
last four years
during that time basketball player
Brittany Greiner and another former
Marine Trevor Reed were released as part
of prisoner swaps but there has been no
apparent progress on a swap for
gershkovitz or Weyland with many asking
what more can the administration do it's
devastating it's very tragic yeah it's
all very sad chairman of the house
Foreign Affairs committee Congressman
Michael McCall is hard at work fighting
for Evan's freedom for the family and
especially his mother I can't imagine
what she's going through and of course
you know colleagues at Wall Street
Journal to see their colleague in a
glass cage obviously not being treated
very well probably has no access to a
doctor you know for the crime he didn't
commit and it's just outrageous and this
has helped Putin operates and sadly
probably not the end of this we're going
to see more of this taking prisoners for
ransom purposes
you know and uh how can we possibly get
him out in the Griner case and it was
very unbalanced in terms of the trade I
mean we were supposed to get Paul Whalen
and Brittany Greiner out they only
released Brittany Greiner who
essentially had like a vape pipe in
exchange for an arms dealer that we
exchanged
who do you think is partly to blame for
that decision should the administration
have stuck and said no it is Paul
Wheeling that we want to to exchange
first he's been there for four years he
should be a priority
yeah I mean uh Paul whale was a marine I
think it was calculated on Putin's part
to uh release the celebrity basketball
star and we're glad that she's home and
then uh still detain the uh the Marine
uh symbolically as a slap in the face I
don't think it was a fair trade and It's
Tricky right because you you want to get
them out but you don't want to encourage
you know further people being in prison
for no reason and to be held hostage as
political pods and that's that's what
we're seeing more and more out of Putin
and Russia
yeah
um when Russia takes an American
shouldn't they be afraid shouldn't they
be real sanctions and how can we set
that how can we make countries more
afraid to take Americans
well projecting strength not weakness uh
letting them know that they're very
harsh consequences if they do this and
letting them know we're not gonna we're
gonna trade um you know prisoners if
that's what has to be done that the
charges should be more equal and not so
disparate as we saw in the Brittany
Greiner trade for the Arms Dealer and I
would argue led to the imprisonment of
you know of Evan that we're seeing today
and in Evan's case this is probably the
worst that I've seen because he was
simply reporting the news and of course
that frightens Putin the truth you know
in a dictatorship they fear the truth
more than anything and it gets out to
his own people and he fears his own
people and so that's precisely why I
think he detained and now imprisoned uh
Evan and uh I'm personally working
through a lot of different channels to
get him out of there
these are very tricky cases they're very
hard because you're really at the mercy
of Putin and I think because we have
rewarded him in the past he's going to
expect that same reward in the future
other than a prisoner swap what other
methods might be used what other avenues
could we take I mean sanctions won't
work because the Russia was so heavily
sanctioned because of Ukraine Invasion
so other than a prisoner swap what are
the other possibilities
well we could do secondary sanctions
which we should have done anyway I mean
the sanctions in place are working okay
but not really like secondary sanctions
would and I think we send a stronger
statement to them this is unacceptable
but you know I think this Administration
has projected weakness all along and it
just emboldens Putin and encourages us
bad behavior
what would your message be to any
Americans living or working in Russia at
the moment or any American who is
thinking about traveling there
I'd be very careful you could be the
victim of one of these political time
you know imprisonment cases and uh to
any reporters certainly in Russia that
uh what happened to Heaven can happen to
you that you could be charged with
espionize just for reporting the truth
about what is happening in Russian and
Ukraine
um so there's a very precarious
dangerous situation I've traveled to
Russia
You Know Myself and I was under very
heavy surveillance
and if you can be compromised they're
going to try to compromise you and if
they can get something out of you in a
prisoner swap they may likely detain
them imprison you you know Paul whalen's
been over there for years now he was
supposed to be part of this last deal
and at the last minute Putin um broke
his promise on that
what is your message to Evan right now
if Evan were able to hear you today what
would you say to him
no we're with you that we're working
every channel possible to get you out
and that we're praying
for you
um we're gonna put and I in the Congress
will continue to put pressure
on Putin in Russia we passed a strong
resolution condemning his wrongful
detainment of evidence and imprisonment
and um we're just not going to tolerate
this holding U.S citizens hostage under
false pretenses and that if they do
continue this and if they don't free
Heaven that in the Congress even if this
Administration won't do it will pursue
secondary sanctions on Putin and Russia
as the fight for Evan's release remains
a priority on Capitol Hill another
years-long fight for an American's
Freedom continues former Marine Paul
whalen's family has been demanding the
release of their loved one for four
years and they have no plans of stopping
until Paul is back home I think that uh
it's hard for people to understand how
something about this changes the people
who are involved in it not just the
person who is incarcerated but the
family as well we speak with Paul's
brother David Whalen I can't even
imagine what it's been like for Paul and
who he is now and not being able to talk
to him and really understand in detail
what his experience has been like the
fear that he may experienced the
uncertainty about his future the anxiety
that he must go through every single day
and so uh I think that that's uh that's
a challenge that everybody in our family
has faced but I can't even imagine what
it's been like for Paul yeah how much do
we know about his current conditions
where is he being held and what is what
is life what is daily life like for him
for the first 18 months he was held at
the Fort of a pre-trial detention in
Moscow and then he was moved in June of
2020 I guess it was to uh ik17 which is
a labor camp in mordovia which is a
republican the Federation and he's been
there for the last three years almost
exactly three years and uh he seems to
be doing fine I mean his he's been
taking care of his health that we've
been sending him what we can as far as
over-the-counter medicines uh food to
supplement the food that they get in
prison which isn't very much he's
allowed four packages a year so the U.S
embassy and the other embassies have
been really good at taking those
packages for us because we don't have
Russian bank accounts we don't have the
ability to get him resources inside the
country so it's difficult but he's doing
the best he can I think he's done a
remarkable job of surviving uh day to
day
now how often are your parents able to
speak to him I believe they've had some
phone calls with him but how often is
there a contact between you him and the
family
uh it's usually on a daily basis it was
on a daily basis up until two or three
weeks ago he was able to make 15-minute
calls to our parents and then there was
a RT news crew came out to the prison
and Paul refused to speak to them and
ever since then the prison guards have
been disrupting the phone calls his
ability to call the Embassy or to call
home and uh it's that sort of
retaliation that uncertainty that you
never really know what's going on day to
day yeah
um going back to when Paul was arrested
what were the Russian accusations
against him and sort of how how wrong
are they
I think they couldn't be more wrong they
accused him of Espionage and uh they
said that a USB drive given to him by a
friend had some sort of state secret on
it no one has ever seen it uh the
lawyers said I'm not sure have seen it
either but uh we certainly don't have
any idea what that was and Paul never
saw it either because he was given the
USB drive and then was immediately
arrested by State security services
hmm
how do you feel of course seeing
Brittany Greiner Trevor Reed be swapped
when Paul has not yet been released
when you're dealing with Russia you
realize that they are willing to do
things at Western countries aren't
willing to do in part because I don't
think they care about the individual
person
um I was thrilled when Brittany Greiner
came home and I was thrilled when Trail
Reed came home because I think if you
start to focus only on Paul and you know
why isn't Paul coming home uh I think
you start to lose your humanity and
become a lot like the Kremlin is
um and so you know I would obviously
love to have my brother home but I don't
begrudge these other Americans uh their
freedom at all
uh how has Paul felt so have you spoken
to him specifically about obviously you
know Trevor coming back to the US and
Brittany coming back to the U.S how does
that make Paul feel
I think he's just like we are uh he's
very disappointed that he has not come
home but I think he understands that uh
it's important to get America's home
when you have the opportunity to do so
and so the Administration has done a
good job of getting Americans home and
we hope that eventually Paul will be one
of those Americans that gets to come
home
uh you've said before that you really
want to keep pressure on the White House
at the moment you really want to keep
this pressure building so that people
you know are constantly thinking about
Paul and how can you do that what do you
need to keep doing what is the message
from from you and the family
our message is really focused on the
White House and we uh and working with
people in the state department or the
National Security Council uh to stay on
top of what what are they doing you know
have they tried something and and if
they have tried it what is the result of
it and to suggest maybe not to wait too
long before they try something else but
at the end of the day it really comes
down to is the Kremlin going to take a
concession and what concession is the US
government willing to make that's really
those are the only uh actions that can
bring Paul home
what would you like all our listeners to
know in what way can they help this
course or keep the voice going
really the best thing you can do for any
prisoner whether it's Paul or Evan
gershkovich or any any uh one who's
detained in this sort of situation is to
remind them about their Humanity I think
one of the things we heard when Brittany
Greiner came home was how much she
appreciated getting letters and mail
from people uh and and Miss Greiner was
very gracious at encouraging people to
write to Paul and so I would say the
same thing go to freepaulwheeland.com
and find the address that's on that
website it's a it's an American address
it's at the state department and send
Paul a letter that's really the best
thing you could do don't send any
packages because he only gets four a
year and we do use that for food and
mail but uh send Paul a letter or a
postcard and just let him know that you
remember him and that you're thinking
about him perfect uh look I'm so
grateful for your time today and um I
hope we get a meet in person one day as
well with Paul too
sounds great Ben I appreciate your time
thanks